Alright guys, congratulations. At this point, you've gotten your first deal and if you're
watching this and you haven't, it's okay. Keep doing the process. Keep putting the reps
in and you will get a deal. But I want to cover what do you do after the deal, right?
You get the deal, the business owner gives you the credit card number, they give you
their information, all that stuff. What do you do then? What I like to do, the last couple
things that I like to do once they've given me the credit card before I end the call is
I let them know, hey, so here's what's going to happen. I'm actually, Mr. Business Owner,
I need first of all, what's the business address? Because I want to have the business address
for the contract. I want to know the legal business name. I'm going to write that down.
And I'm going to tell them, I'm going to be sending over two documents. I'm going to be
sending over an exclusivity agreement, which is how I phrase it, which basically will tell
you that this is 100% exclusive. It indicates the price. And by the way, and I'll say this,
by the way, most people, I know it's 2,000 bucks a month, most people just like to do
the 500 a week, so it's not as big of a deal. Do you want to do 500 a week? 2,000. Doesn't
matter to me, okay? Let's do the 500 a week. Cool. I like weekly, by the way, guys, because
I can monitor it more and you actually make a little bit more money over the course of
the year. So I prefer the weekly, but it's up to you. And I'll say, I'm going to have
two documents coming to, what's the best email? Let me grab that. I'll grab the email. Okay.
I'm going to send over the exclusivity agreement and I'm going to send over a credit card preauthorization.
All that's going to do is that's going to legally allow me to charge your card every
week so I don't have to bug you every single week. Okay. So all I need is those two signatures
and then who do you want the leads going to? Okay. Like what email, what address, et cetera?
I just grab it right there. So, okay, so it's going to go to you. Cool. What's the number?
Okay. Cool. And what's the email? Cool. So awesome. This sounds good. All I need you
to do, I'm going to get this going immediately. We'll have calls coming to you. Could be as
early as today. It may take a day or two depending on what comes in, but I'm going to get those
two documents. All I need is two signatures and we are ready to rock and roll. Awesome.
Thanks Brian. Thanks Jack. Thanks Tara. Thanks Tracy. Whatever. Boom. End the call. Okay.
Immediately. I don't go take a pee. I don't go get a drink. I don't treat myself to lunch.
I get the credit card signed. I get the deal run. So first thing I do is I run the card.
Okay. I set up the, I create the customer, set up the subscription, run the card, which
I'm going to show you how to do. Then I send over the contract and I send over the preauthorization
before I take a deep breath because this deal ain't done yet. Okay. You do have the card,
but the deal ain't done yet. So let's hop over to the screen. Okay guys. So first thing
that I do is I come over to Stripe. I'm not going to go through how to set up Stripe.
Google it, YouTube it. It's very simple. Go set up a Stripe account. If you have questions,
by the way, they've all been asked in the Facebook group, go and Google Stripe and you'll
see people have had some very specific questions. You can go look at those. Okay. Not difficult.
I like Stripe. I know the fees are a little high or whatever. I don't care. I believe
money loves speed. I'll take that for the speed, the convenience and all that. I love
Stripe. Okay. So what you're going to do is once you come in, you're going to go over
to the customers tab. Okay. And you are going to add a customer and you're going to put
the customer in here. We'll just use this example. So we'll call it John Doe. Okay.
John Doe. I only fill out two things. I do the name and then the email. So John at Doe.com
add customer. Okay. That's step one. Step two is you need to come over and you need
a product. Okay. And what I do is I go and I push add product. Okay. And I'm going to
call this Queen Creek Concrete Leads. Okay. I leave the description blank or you can copy
the same thing down. It doesn't matter. And if you're going to do monthly, you're going
to put in 2000. If you're going to do weekly, you can put in 500, but do not forget to change
this to weekly. Okay. Because if you do, if you don't, you're going to be charging 500
a month and not realize it. Okay. So change it to weekly and just save it. Very simple.
So we've created the customer. We've created the product. Now you can just go back to your
customer list, click on John and go over where it says subscriptions and push create. You
can do it there or you can go to actions and push create subscription. Doesn't matter.
It's the same. And what's going to happen is you're going to search for first of all
the customers there, then you're going to search for the product, which usually pops
up first. Stripe smart enough to know you're probably going to be setting up that product,
that subscription, click on your product says 500 a week. And now here's what you're going
to do. Okay. You're going to go over and it's going to start on today's date and I'm going
to put it to go forever. I'm not going to have a stop on it because I don't want there
to be a stop and me losing money. I would rather the customer hit me up and say, Hey,
you overcharge me and me refund it. And I lose a couple of bucks then to not get paid.
So I leave it as forever because I plan on working with these guys forever. Just so you
know, six months is just the beginning. Okay. You don't have to mess with any of this stuff,
blah, blah, blah. Okay. And then what you're going to do because you already have the credit
card number is you're going to go over and hit automatically charge a credit payment
method on file, push add a payment. And guess what? You put in the credit card number, you
put in the month and the year and you put in the CVC and you push add. Okay. And once
you do that, I'm not, I don't have a credit card here. You're going to push start subscription.
And that is immediately going to charge the customer immediately. Okay. And you're done.
That is like, the crazy part is you are done with Stripe. It will continue to build them
every single month forever or week. And you were done. That's how simple it is. This is
why I love Stripe. That took me 30 seconds. Okay. That's it. That's it. And this is what
I love about this too. I like to run the payment first before I worry about the contract because
that card, it'll say insufficient funds. And now you're like, okay, this guy, this gate,
this lady, she's yanking me around or this guy, this lady, they don't have money. Okay.
Or they gave me the wrong card or they're messing with me or whatever, but you're going
to know right there. So payments done. Okay. And it's set up. Then I'm going to go over
and this is going to be, it's going to be included as a download. It's also in the file
section of Stripe. You're going to fill out the lead generation and exclusivity agreement.
Now, the only thing you're going to need to change on this because this is just a template
is you need to go and change your information and just do it once and have it saved. Okay.
So that's your company and all that, all that good stuff. And you're going to need to change
down here in the governing law. You need to change this to your state and your county.
So it should not say Washington County and it should not say Utah. Okay. That is it.
And if you want to make sure you can search Utah, but those are the only two places is
those two spots, change those, change your information. And then what you're going to
do is you're going to drop in your customer's information. Okay. So I'll typically go file,
make a copy so I can save my template. And then I'm going to put John, sorry, client
is John's Concrete. Okay. Name of the company as I put, or sorry, name is John Doe address,
blah, blah, blah, whatever, email john at doe.com. Okay. And only other thing I add
here is I will put location is Queen Creek AZ industry is, and if you want, you can just
do flatwork concrete if you want to, if you guys just agreed to flatwork and not decorative
and change the term. So six months, whatever, put that in there. And then the monthly fee
or you can change it to say weekly fee. So in this case, I'm going to put weekly fee
is going to be 500 a month or 500 a week. And that's it. And then what you're going
to do is you're going to go file, download as a PDF. Okay. That's it. You're going to
come over and I like to use doc hub. Okay. The reason I like to use doc hub is because
you get five free signatures. It's very simple. But you can use doc. You sign. It doesn't
matter what you use. I've always used doc hub for my lead generation clients. Okay.
You're going to come over here and you're going to sign up for the free. I'm going to
sign in really quick with my account. So give me one moment. All right guys, here we are
in doc hub. Very simple. You're just going to go new document. Okay. You're going to
upload it and you're going to go to your downloads and you're going to find that download
that you had. Okay. And you're going to want to name it something else than this. So I'll
change it to put, you know, whatever I'll put queen up, shoot, sorry. Okay. I'll usually
name it like this. Queen Creek concrete. And then I'll put, um, like John's concrete dash
flat fee lead generation agreement, blah, blah, blah. I want this to be very, I'm thinking,
okay, what happens if this client does a back charge or tries to refund? I want this to
show like, I want striped look at this and go, okay, this guy could have never been confused.
The document is called lead generation agreement. So he can't claim he didn't know. Okay. So
just, just overkill, but I like to name it something there. It's also easily searchable.
And then you're going to go and do a couple of easy things. Okay. You're going to hit
this a tool and you're going to go drop in the date. So today's date is 23 June. Okay.
Make it look good. Don't just slop it in there. Okay. And then again, June 23rd and 23 June,
which clearly I'm being sloppy here. Boom. Okay. 23rd June. Okay. And that is all you
need in terms of what you need to fill out. And then what you need to do is you need to go
push sign. You're going to need to create your signature the first time. But then once you have
it, you can just come in here, drop your signature. And by the way, just for those of you that missed
that, just click sign and it's going to, you're going to grab your signature and draw it down.
Okay. So I signed and then you're going to go to this little thing right here. It says manage
fields. You're going to click on it and you're going to go to the signature one and you're going
to drop it right here. Okay. And you're going to go over to the assignee and you're going to put
john at doe.com and you're going to add. Okay. If you can see his initials, J O, which I don't
know why it says J O, but it should say J D or I don't know, but it says J O whatever,
but it says right here, he's assigned. So this says if that would be not assigned,
I'm going to assign in that field and you are done. All you need to do is push prepare sign
request. And when I push send request, this is going to send him to the email that you put on
file right here. It's going to send him the document that he or she can open up and with
their finger or from their computer sign, and it will send you a copy and you are done with
the contract. That's it. Okay. Very, very simple. You're done. Then what I do is I hop over to the
credit card authorization. So I go to new documents. I already have this thing saved as an
authorization. I'll search for it. I don't know if I have it downloaded, so I might need to do that
really quick. I do not. So let me go over to this. And by the way, this is in the file section. Let
me download this on this computer really quick. Boom. Go back over to doc hub upload and let's
look under my downloads. Credit card authorization is hiding right there. Beautiful. And same thing,
you're just going to fill this out. So again, I'll probably put their company name. I'll put
John's concrete credit card authorization. Okay. I'm going to put the, I'm going to use the a tool
and I'm going to go card holder's name. John's or sorry, John dough. I'm going to make it look
nice. I'm going to put the card number, uh, four, four, four, four, four, four, four, four, four,
four, four, make it look nice. Okay. And then I'm going to put the expiration date. Let's call zero
seven of 26, make it look nice. And then I don't know why this one doesn't include it. We need to
just fix the template, but I always add the CBC here just so I don't honestly, so I don't forget
it. Cause I'm going to throw that piece of paper away. So let's say it's six, four, two. Okay.
Billing address eight, four, sorry, eight, four, seven. I know that's mine. We're just using an
example. And then you're going to fill us out for them. So I John dough. Boom. Authorize whatever
my company is called. This is my lead gen company called EMM ventures, LLC to charge my credit card,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then you're going to put the date in June 23rd, 2022. Done.
And you're going to go and one more time to this field right here, grab that signature box, put it
in here. And you're going to add John at dough.com, push add and assign it to him. You push prepare
sign request. You send the request and guys, you are done. You have the credit card charged. You
have the auto pay set up through Stripe. You have the a flat fee lead generation exclusivity agreement
sent out, filled out correctly. He just, he or she just needs to sign it. You have the credit card
sent out, filled out correctly. He or she just needs to sign it. That will send you copies
and you are done. And that my friends is what you call a big boy, big girl deal. That is start to
finish exactly how you do it. That's all I do. So after the call, I do all those things. We're done.
All the formalities are done. And then I'm immediately going to go and make sure that I
go to Colorado, send him the leads directly. I'm going to go into my Weebly forms or WordPress.
I'm going to make sure he's getting the, uh, the quote forms instant, uh, the, what they call them
web submissions, whatever. And we are done. So guys, here's the game. You do this over and over
and over. If you can do it one time, if you can make a thousand dollars one time, you can literally
repeat that a hundred times to get to a hundred thousand dollars per month. That's exactly what I
did. Go and do it as many times as you can and go and hit those goals.